welcome everybody we have once again
once again for the second time in her
career Donald Trump's new press
secretary Kaley maca nanny or McKenna
knee
I find it linguistically more natural to
say McKenna knee but I'm hearing it more
often said maca nanny is going to be
holding a press briefing this is Donald
Trump's latest press secretary his
previous most recent previous secretary
Stephanie Grisham held zero press
briefings during her entire time in that
role Kayleigh maca nany held one I guess
it was was it fraught no way not Friday
what was it the previous Friday no it
was Friday yeah this past Friday
she held her first press briefing and
she promised not to lie during it and
then told at least five lies which I
will go over with you momentarily
expecting this to start at the top of
the hour she seems to be taking after
Donald Trump and at least on Friday
started later than scheduled so we will
see what time it ultimately starts but
what we can be almost sure of is that
there will be plenty of disinformation
and propaganda upcoming let's do a quick
update of the latest coronavirus data we
are now just shy of 3.8 million official
clay cases globally and 262 just shy of
two hundred and sixty three thousand
deaths globally the trend lines are not
particularly good eighty-one thousand
new cases yesterday another 73,000 so
far today yesterday nearly six thousand
people died today so far forty-nine
hundred people died here in the United
States the latest official numbers are
1.25 million cases the real number is of
course much more just under seventy four
thousand deaths one of the things that
we are seeing is that the numbers are
not really slowing down in terms of
deaths
2,350 deaths yesterday the highest in a
while we are already at 1,500 today now
one thing that is interesting is states
that are opening early
sort of like Texas for example they are
starting to see cases increase and what
what matters here is not so much the raw
numbers but the the increase
percentage-wise and if you go back to
April 27th year you will see that the
average has been increasing if these
numbers continued Texas will be a prime
hotspot in ten days there are other
examples as well active cases in Texas
after leveling off in late April now
have started to go back up and and that
is accelerating deaths of course lag a
little bit but we are still starting to
see a similar trend generated there I
expect we were going to see this in a
number of different different states
Donald Trump is no longer talking about
deaths he's talking about reopening he's
talking about the economy stock market
how the cupboards were bare and he's
great at everything all the time no
matter what looking at the latest
testing data what we see is that we
still are not testing very much per
capita it is true and I'm glad to see
that compared to for example early April
and late March where we often were
testing you know in the low six figures
we are now more regularly starting to
see 250,000 tests a day close to 300
tests a thousand tests a day on some
days we're not even close to where we
need to be as I've said before to start
having a conversation about testing we
need to get to 500 thousand a day and we
need to use that to get to a million a
day and then two million a day we are
still struggling to get to 300 thousand
a day but we're better off than we were
at the beginning of April that's at
least something welcomed if you're
watching on Twitter twitch Facebook or
YouTube I so appreciate everybody who's
here one of the places where we are live
is on twitch at twitch.tv slash David
Pakman I do want to say thanks to mules
Casey get Trump out 2020 and AJ Scorpia
all who have subscribed with twitch
prime which I absolutely love I want to
say thank you to Louie Johnson who just
made a $2 pledge on patreon and is
today's first support
of the day and also Robert Cahill who
has signed up at join pakman.com and is
supporter number two today as you can
see we have a bar to fill there for lack
of a better term if you're watching on
YouTube welcome make sure you are aware
that you can get your message up on the
screen in the lower left if you send a
super chat I have some super chats
already to talk about Andrew Moore sent
to super chat and says hey David thanks
for keeping the show interesting your
showmanship is rivaled only by Freddie
Mercury David Bowie or David Bowie to
quote who was that artist was it Avril
Lavigne who said David Bowie and Michael
Jackson I love it thanks to Katie R and
dolphin girl for subscribing on YouTube
waffles Jarrell's says Germany opens
schools theaters bars anything
yeah I'm not exactly up to speed on
what's going on in Germany but one of
the things that's important to look at
is if we look at some of these countries
UK may not be doing quite so well yet
but if you look at Spain for example
that is the type of curve that you want
to see for cases this is the type of
curve you want to see for deaths that
makes sense if you look at Italy look at
Italy's case numbers that is what you
want to see once again you look at
deaths that is what you want to see
although a little bit of a spike there
if you look at France France has done a
very good job look at what's going on in
France with the cases and then if you
look at deaths in France as well looking
very very good you look at Germany
Germany which has handled this
relatively well that's what you want to
see you look at deaths in Germany okay
lagging a little bit but again that's
what you want to see then you look at
the United States and it's just a
disgusting mess an absolute disgusting
mess sad and tragic quite frankly okay
Zachary foster says not for reopening
now but don't you think it's ridiculous
for online doctors like Deena Grayson
and Eugene gue tweeting things like
Texas reopened and the day
and all of the sudden has more deaths
yeah you need you need 7 to 10 days to
see the impact but here's now here's
something I do want to mention there's a
psychological impact when you hear the
state is going to reopen people already
start behaving less carefully so you're
right the effect of reopening is not
truly seen in the numbers for seven to
ten days maybe even 14 but a lot of
people if you are told next week we're
opening you see that as a signal that
today you can start doing stuff so if
you know a week ahead of time that a
state's going to be opening we knew with
Georgia earlier we knew with Florida
stuff Texas people immediately start
behaving more in a less safe way so you
actually often do already start to see
case increases by the day of the
official open because people have
already started going out a week before
important to keep in mind
unknown prodigy says my mommy says hi
again give a shout-out to mom hello Ms
unknown prodigy great to see you here
zesty African says would a win for Trump
help usher in an era for progressives
acceleration ISM I don't believe so I
have numerous clips about acceleration
ISM on my channel and I welcome you
checking it out
Matt Chavez says Brian Tyler Cohen
collaboration now the people wanted I'd
be glad to collaborate with him anytime
I have no contact with him though we
don't we've never been in touch so if
anybody wants to anybody can introduce
us I would be interested in doing a
collaboration with Brian he's doing very
good work Phyllis städel says have you
heard the flu infection fatality rate is
closer to 0.04 many people generically
use point one but this is actually the
case fatality rate I have seen some
reports about that indeed a rich ropa
thak says add k2 Kyle : skis initials
and it's a disaster
nasty questions says I live in North
Texas many people at restaurants and
malls are open I'm staying inside
Michael foster says love your stream as
always David like this
dream yes take Michaels advice if you're
watching on YouTube make sure -
absolutely smash I want that like button
and the subscribe button
I want them pulverized I want them
aerosolized for lack of a better term
thank you to Jodi Dillon or NSA for
subscribing on YouTube
I very much appreciate that okay let me
step away briefly from super chats but
keep them coming keep them coming
couple of little notices for everybody
important show announcements number one
The Daily Show as of today has gotten
10% longer we've extended we've
elongated the program the daily program
by 10 percent we have now pushed our
broadcast our on radio and TV to the
limit it's at a it's at a breaking point
my friends because we have we expanded
the show ten percent a year ago we've
done another 10 percent advertisers hate
me for it but what I care about is
making sure we get you as much content
during that hour as possible so 10
percent more show starting today number
starting this week number two we have a
new David Pakman show newsletter which
will be converted in the next couple of
weeks into a dade daily print digest of
the show okay
this is free oh I sorry I froze there
had to be rebooted it's completely free
fat but I got you to look up though
right if you had stepped away from your
phone you can sign up for it on my
website david pakman.com you just sign
up for the newsletter or you can do it
at david pakman.com we are right now
it's just our regular newsletter but
over the next two weeks we are going to
be extending that filling it up chock
full of good material and it will serve
as a sort of daily digital print dyed
written digest of the show free take
advantage of it if you like it I love it
and then number three we have a clip
coming out from today's program if
you're a member on my website you can
already see this with peace and love and
it's called Pakman can't satisfy
everyone okay and over the last few
weeks I have seen that there is an
increasingly loud and belligerent
slice of my audience that is making
demands of me but they are demands that
will never be satisfied unless I become
a different person and throw away
everything that I believe right so today
I have a message to those folks and
really to everybody with an apology to
some people as well you'll see me
apologize in a segment today and I there
are people who are never going to be
satisfied with this program and with my
perspective and I'm addressing that
today as well so many many exciting
things for you to look at okay today
though we are standing by for Kaylee
McKenna nior Macon Mackin Annie
depending on your preference I want to
remind you that during her first press
briefing last week she was asked will
you pledge not to lie to us and she had
this dazed look for most of the press
briefing and she said she wasn't going
to lie take a look here you have my word
on that
as to the timing of the briefings we do
plan to do them now unfortunately she
immediately told 4 lies which I've
noticed noted here immediately after
saying she would never lie she said that
the Muller report totally exonerated
Trump in fact it's the opposite Robert
Muller said that he cannot exonerate
Donald Trump on obstruction of justice
think whatever you want what she said
was a lie
number two she said the Muller report
cost 40 million dollars the truth is
that the Moller report strictly speaking
costs 32 million dollars but more
importantly it recovered more than 42
million dollars the Moller report
recovered more money than it cost so it
was another lie number three she said
that not a single person has died due to
lack of a ventilator that's very
difficult to say for sure anecdotally we
know of multiple people being hooked up
to the same ventilator which you're not
supposed to do we know of people being
taken off of ventilators because other
kovat patients needed them so certainly
that's deceptive if not untrue she also
said that the entire Michael Flynn
prosecution was Bo
which I mean he admitted to lying right
he lied to the FBI that's a crime so she
lied four times after promising not to
lie what she should have been asked
about is this and she was not I hope
she'll be asked about it today
take a listen I mean isn't it just a
matter of protecting us our national
security really being at stake and he's
sort of the last line of defense there
or firstly I should say absolutely this
president will always put America first
he will always protect American citizens
we will not see diseases like the corona
virus come here we will not see
terrorism come here anymore not see
diseases like coronavirus come here of
course that was judged a lie by virtue
of the fact that time passes and we now
have 1.2 or close to 1.3 million cases
in the United States that's what she
should be asked about my friends and
hopefully she will be today ok other
super chats that are coming in here a
lot going on today we are standing by
for Caylee Mackin Annie at the top of
the hour judging from how many reporters
are in the room it may be a little bit
longer than that but that's ok more time
that we can talk about other things
Alexander the Snivy says libertarians
are pseudo-intellectuals that go simple
for the free market and the 1% whoa whoa
shots fired
Matthias Germany says Trump sees
Americans as warriors what is your
opinion I don't find the war language
generally productive to dealing with the
actual medical issue so I try to stay
out of that
Emilio chloro knee says would you
consider buzzing your head not really
not really no Walker Anderson says
everyone should listen to ben shapiro
podcast from today proves why david's
corona arguments about Trump and
Republicans are disingenuous all right
that means you do what you want
bill Kittleman says David I cannot
afford to be a member I am permanently
disabled and have no job I love your
show keep on doing a great job I
appreciate your support I'm sorry to
hear that bill maybe somebody will have
a gift membership for Bill let me thank
just a couple of other people Krista
for Olin is new member number three
today on my website and Nicholas Corrado
is new member number four thank you so
much I'm gonna mention this once and not
again and if this resonates with you
then then fantastic this is a program
that's mostly funded by our viewers we
have seen YouTube revenue dropped thirty
five percent because of the invisible
scourge we have seen a couple of
advertisers postpone or or bail on ad
campaigns so we're increasingly
dependent on people who say hey I'm
gonna just grab a membership on your
website or make a pledge on patreon so I
don't want anyone's last dollar we saw
seven hundred and twenty two people
cancel memberships in March and April
and I get why I get it we're all in this
together
but we're trying to do as much as we can
including expanding our our weekly
output of content if a couple bucks a
month works for you
grab a membership grab a membership at
join pakman.com the coupon code 2020 now
drops the price to two bucks a month you
can pay for a year at once and then it's
only a dollar eighty every single person
who does this not only will you have my
undying gratitude but I will also thank
you live on stream it's quick it's easy
you can use PayPal you can use any
credit or debit card if you prefer you
can also use patreon and we'll count it
to our goal of 25 you can go to
patreon.com/scishow it all counts
everything counts and we have been
fortunately we're not we're sort of
treading water
we're under water but only a little bit
seven hundred and twenty two people
cancelled but many hundreds have
subscribed thanks to fine folks like you
and that's a good thing and we are
hoping to come out of this bigger and
better than ever and folks like you are
a big part of that okay let's see a few
other Oh over on Twitch I want to thank
Belle Wolff and Henry Engvall for
subscribing with prime always a
beautiful thing oh okay Michael Kern's
has just donated twenty bucks
towards bills membership that's
beautiful so listen bill get in touch
via my website bill Kittleman I will set
you up with a membership thanks to
Michael Kern's that's a beautiful thing
I love it Michael really appreciate it
get in touch bill you've got yourself a
free membership community community what
a beautiful thing this you know this
isn't happening over on it a bill
Mitchell's Twitter page I can assure you
Mark Levin is not doing what what we're
doing here community wise from the
standpoint of community so I love it
very much appreciate it
okay other super chats that are coming
in
unknown prodigy says someone should ask
has Trump ever lied catch-22 pair T Wren
says can anyone put some justice to the
mouth of Sauron
sorry Trump except popularity and media
impact pair you know I love you I don't
know what you're talking about I don't
know if you're translating from Swedish
via Google Translate but I am struggling
to know what you're saying but I love
your long term support Chris K says so
how long does her nose need to grow
before we stop watching yeah I expect a
lot of dishonesty today for sure a lot a
lot of dishonesty no doubt about it
Walker Anderson says David ignores
Sweden's successful strategy and the
plurality of Democrat governors praising
the federal government's approach he is
a disingenuous actor listen um III have
no ideological compunction when it comes
to saying a particular strategy for
dealing with the virus is good or bad we
don't know about the Sweden situation
long-term what we know in the short term
is that their death rate is higher than
many other countries
Sweden's death rate because of their
strategy is higher they are not actually
near herd immunity you need to get we
believe between 60 and 70 percent
infection to get to herd immunity the
possibility is that in the long term
over the three waves that are expected
maybe Sweden will be better off in the
short turn Sweden is seeing a higher
death rate okay Jodi Dylan Aaron say
says hey David big fan from South Africa
thank you I appreciate that very much
dragon horizon says last dollar I I know
you're kidding I know you're kidding
Townsend Koch says David did you know
Jesse Lee Peterson once interviewed
Michelle Alexander of new Jim Crow Frank
Fame hilarious and amazing you should
check it out that sounds compelling and
I'm gonna look at that later Michael
Kern's um getting him buying a
membership for Bill Kittleman I love it
Danny Thompson says applause for the
print version I have a hard time
watching and listening to the hour-long
show but I am a voracious reader like a
book a day and now feel great I will be
better informed of all things Pakman
soon yes absolutely Danny thank you very
much okay let me say thank you to
Peppa's e-1 for subscribing with twitch
Prime and M Sanjib
for subscribing with prime Chris
Davidson says I'll buy bill hit almond a
year membership what's the best way to
do that Chris you know what somebody
already did it I appreciate the
generosity but somebody did it already
so Bill's got himself a membership
upcoming sherry Kaczynski has subscribed
on YouTube Pere says how can I pay for
Bill for a web membership the generosity
is inspiring we've got bill taken care
of thanks to Michael Kern's Ryan Macon
says love watching from the UK sad to
see what is happening both here and
there agreed Zachary Foster says should
hospitalizations be the primary factor
for severity of growth scott Gottlieb
says we are getting better but very
slowly yeah that that's not let me see
if I can pull up the Massachusetts data
because I'm familiar with it it's not
crazy to be looking at hospitalizations
Massachusetts has a nice dashboard that
they update pretty regularly this was
this is from yesterday and one of the
things that it contains is this is let's
see testing case growth county by county
hospitalizations and what I love is at
the bottom here its net change in
hospitalizations
and that so you've got the blue line is
the number hospitalized obviously for
that to go down in the bottom you would
see like a net decrease 92 or 43 or
whatever the case may be that is a good
metric to look at it doesn't tell you
everything but it is certainly an
important metric to consider um
Samuel Lopez says boy I started this W
when I started that's great to hear from
you
Matias Germany says can you describe
what scourge or scorch means okay so let
me pull up the definition so there
what's funny about the word scourge or
scourge is that Trump mispronounces it
regularly Trump has for whatever reason
I don't believe it's a valid
pronunciation yeah so if you look at the
phonetic pronunciation we can even play
it
scourge there you go it's pronounced
scourge and it means a whip used as an
instrument of punishment or what we mean
by that is that the corona virus is
punishing us right it is a punishment
that's what scourge essentially means
Trump pronounces it scourge and nobody
seems to have corrected him or if they
have he doesn't care so that's that Madi
ice PD says David perhaps we can set up
a Community Fund to help our less
privileged viewers get memberships PS
thanks for streaming today Cheers yeah
you know i-i've been trying to think of
how to do this and for a while people
would email me and say I want a free
website membership and I was trying to
think of a way with a spreadsheet a
Google spreadsheet where people could go
and look at it and pick somebody and buy
a membership for them I've not figured
out the logistics of it yet to be
perfectly frank but I would love I would
love to do something like that I think
there are a lot of members probably
hundreds of current members who would
buy a membership for somebody else and I
would love to figure out a way to do it
that also isn't subject to some kind of
vandalism having a Google spreadsheet
where people can add their name and then
somebody else can kind of like check off
and say hey I got a membership for this
person it's ripe for abuse and trolling
so I'd love to
you do it I just don't know exactly the
right way at this point in time okay
I've got a few other people to thank on
my website really really great people
let me make sure I pronounce these names
as perfectly as possible
michael fitz herbert i've not heard that
last name before Fitzherbert is new
member number five on my website join
pakman.com Walter Washington is new
member number six today at join
pakman.com ryan holding is new member
number seven at join pakman.com lori
gerund or gerund is new member number
eight today thanks Lori Adam airy or
Adam Avery is new member number nine
today Tyler Grimes has subscribed and
his new member number ten jessica pearcy
you were new member number eleven George
Shea is new member number twelve and
Lucas s-sir Lucas Sr is lucky 13 thanks
Lucas very much appreciate your support
and a lot of these great people are
taking advantage of that coupon code
2020 now which chops the price of a
membership to just two bucks a month let
me remember of course to thank our
followers over on Twitch people like
ramekin beast
I love ramekins myself who is a twitch
prime subscriber dead Zed's Hell's
Kitchen Graham BAM and yes smiles yes
smiles love it absolutely love it other
questions coming in Shane beam whoa
that's rolled Pat past me Shane beam
says just adding towards the bill
membership fund I love it bill you are
very well positioned for a membership at
this point waffles Durrell's says
positive kovat test from december in
france what are your thoughts you know I
was in in France in December and both my
girlfriend and I believe it's possible
plausible that we had the virus and
seeing that there were cases in France
in December seems to make it more more
light Leigh's more plausible I do plan
on getting an antibody test soon I'm
just way
because the the one you can get easily
is the quest pharmaceuticals request
labs one there's like ten labs within a
few miles of where I live and I was
going to do it today but I want to wait
to see there's this thing we're the let
the labs have to self certify that the
tests are accurate you know that's like
saying businesses will regulate
themselves we know it's it's BS so I'm
waiting a little bit to see if you know
we get an efficacy signal for lack of a
better term I want to make sure that if
I go and pay a hundred bucks for one of
these tests that it's actually accurate
so maybe next week okay um quirky quips
says I may have misheard but if the dnc
were to remove Biden it's possible to
put Hillary Obama on the ticket shake-up
or a nightmare give me your ideas look
listen unless Joe Biden dies or is in a
coma he's the nominee that that's you
know unless we find out he you know shot
someone on Fifth Avenue or something
like that so I don't even know that it's
worth looking at that stuff
sherry Kaczynski says love your show so
much thank you sherry
Townsend coke says Faye that eco
Finkelstein is very interesting thanks
yes I cite 'add faded eco yesterday on
the show he is a fellow Argentinian
hilariously his dad and my dad were
friends decades ago in Argentina and he
is an expert on populism and
totalitarianism and the difference is
between left and right wing populism he
teaches at the new school in New York
City look him up look him up excellent
guy fortnight fortnight says hi David I
thank God for people like you online I
thought something was wrong with how I
was raised because of how Trump and so
many of his followers seemingly have the
support of so many influential people
thank you for the message and the the
very generous support I really
appreciate that
azeema Abu Khalil great to see you as
Eames been around the show for a while
Azim says Trump's conduct during the
crisis and by extension his presidency
surely should be enough to convince
never Biden people of the stark disc
repin sees between Joe and Donald right
common sense says yes Reddit and Twitter
say maybe not so you know we will see
how it works out in November
zesty African says are there any African
or Latin American revolutionaries in the
last hundred years that you appreciate
or even love appreciate or let you I
have to think about that a little bit
appreciate sure you know love I don't
really love any politicians I just don't
you know they're just people these lead
leaders are just people so love is you
know that's a term I reserved more for
people I know personally
wake up style has subscribed on YouTube
Madeline Welsh sends a super chat Danny
Thompson says here's a challenge for
those of us able to afford it I am a
YouTube member already I just added a
second membership on David's site and
I'm not canceling YouTube anyone else
wanna accept this challenge Danny I love
what you're doing danny has been a very
generous supporter of the show and I
really appreciate the support Danny bill
Kittleman says thank you very much to
the person that donated yes bill
Kittleman asked for a membership and for
people offered to buy one for Bill and
one person already did so make sure you
email me Bill and I will get that set up
for you in the meantime let me say thank
you to Alou in the cryst oh boy who has
subscribed with twitch Prime and hallo
raven who has subscribed with prime
couple of other people to thank
dorian brown has subscribed on my
website and his new member number 14
Keith Collins has subscribed has made a
patreon pledge and we're going to count
it Danny Thompson has as we just heard
gotten a second membership on my website
that's number 16 and I also want to say
thanks to Francisco Javier he menace but
it is wow that's a mouthful who is new
member number 17 I would guess that Paco
as we often call people named Francisco
I would guess that Francisco is Catholic
going by the four names but that is just
a guess my friends just a guess and if
it turns out Francisco is Jewish then I
love it I love it no matter what
okay Cheryl Robert says thank you for
your great videos many blessings
millennial cooking corner says choose a
trusted person to be membership mediator
that's an interesting idea yeah that
could work
ken H says under over time to the first
live from Mackin Annie is it five
minutes all right let me think about
that she's going to come out and read a
bunch of stuff first before taking
questions will she lied during that part
or will it take until she has to answer
questions I think that she will lie
within three minutes I think she will
lie within three minutes let's actually
game it out when she comes out when she
starts speaking I will run a stopwatch
on my phone and we will see if she tells
a lie
within the first three minutes or if it
takes longer than three minutes we will
see okay Alicia does adulting says could
people buy a free membership from your
website and others buy a gifting
membership then the free ones get
fulfilled in order like twitch yes but
we would need to add that functionality
to the website that's not functionality
that we currently have I need to talk to
my web developer about it quirky quips
says Biden due to sexual allegations his
possible cognitive impairment I guess I
misheard okay Barry Lee says David do
David do you think Trump will fight the
results in November if he loses in court
I don't know that I know what I think
Trump will claim it was rigged if he
loses by a small margin but I think
ultimately he will leave it won't be
what we call peacefully but he will he
will leave is my belief can I get a beer
has subscribed on YouTube
Robert Smith says David I love your
commentary I was the one who attempted
to correct your pronunciation of Caylee
mackaninee lol but I was it was really
just in jest oh okay I don't even know
that I saw that Robert I you know just
I've heard it pronounced McKenna nee and
Mac and Annie and you know that's that's
the story
Gayle Burnett has subscribed on YouTube
Nicholas Corrado and Jan Shutts send
super chats Jan says David I'm concerned
that there will be a standoff when it
comes time for Trump to leave office
Ruby Ridge or Waco Texas style ending
Hyuk no I don't think so I think Trump
will certainly I I'm more worried his
supporters will become violent if they
believe it was rigged but I I think
Trump ultimately will leave office I
believe that he will let me say thank
you to Ryan wild group who is new member
number 18 on my website today we've been
a little short of the goal in some
recent streams but we're getting close
we're actually getting close today and I
believe that with the right effort we
will get there we will get there if
you're just joining this second press
briefing for Donald Trump's new press
secretary was scheduled to start at the
top of the hour 15 minutes ago it has
not yet started we are expecting it to
start anytime although the press
briefing room is still a little bit
empty a little bit empty so hopefully it
starts soon we see Fox News reporter
John Roberts here
I guess about to deliver some kind of
live pre-briefing a message to the Fox
News audience but otherwise relatively
quiet in the press briefing room so far
let's see here
Brad Partington sends a super chat
Robert Mifflin says left online gets
tricked by populist gabbard etc I have a
video that came out yesterday I can tell
you the exact top subject or title of it
the title is hold on a second the title
is oh boy where is it crap I can't find
it it's something like social democracy
is being destroyed by populism and I
talk about exactly that issue
Michael Hank Lee says you should go over
the bed
it's of membership yes the two primary
membership benefits on my website are
every day at 3 p.m.
roughly you get a full hour commercial
free episode all of that day's content
you get it all my friends and an extra
15 to 20 minute bonus show where I'm
joined by our producer Patrick Ford
currently self isolating at his
apartment and you get all of that at
roughly 3:00 p.m. Eastern Time your
alternative is not to get the bonus show
which i think is one of the best
elements that we produce and to wait
around for short clips to publish or
late at night for a with commercials
episode to publish and those are
benefits that people enjoy very very
strongly those are the main things we
also every once in a while will do
Members Only Town Hall's the monthly
Members Only newsletter and a bunch of
other very very exciting stuff so that
the benefits are you know we've been
looking at them very powerfully I think
is what I would say mr. lieutenant pink
great to see you mr. lieutenant pink has
been around for a while thank you
do you know any Welsh speakers from
Argentina no I'm part Welsh and have
always been fascinated by Patagonia
interesting no I don't know any Welsh
folks in Argentina I but this reminds me
by the way
because you said Welsh Brit this made me
think of British I am currently reading
the book machines like us by the great
British writer Ian McEwan and it's an
alternative history where it's 1982
argentina won the Falklands War and the
UK is trying to win it back and Alan
Turing the great code breaker of the
World War 2 era survived and worked on
artificial intelligence and humanoid
robots are something people can buy and
own excellent book excellent book I'm
half way through if you enjoy reading
hello check this book out Ian McEwan
machines like us it will probably make
it onto my book recommendation segment
at some point in time
okay parathion says a bit confused I
think I am a web member but not a
YouTube member what is a YouTube member
so YouTube's membership is totally
different if you become a YouTube member
you get a little icon like for example a
user named none seriously has a yellow
icon because they've been a member for 7
months
user Lima Roenick has a red one because
they've been a member for 5 months your
messages are highlighted in chat and
it's YouTube's only separate from
website so from what it looks like pair
you are a website member and not a
YouTube member Jared Johnson coming in
from nowhere with a 500 Mexican peso
super Chad says David I am on
unemployment for the first time in my
life and I just got my first check I was
working I honestly I appreciate I don't
know that you should be sending me 500
Mexican pesos
I was working 40 hours a week for a
fortune 500 company yet my current
unemployment check gives me about 2,000
a month more than when I had actually
been working oh my god that sounds
complex complex ok I appreciate you
letting me know Jared and are you in
Mexico you're getting Mexican
unemployment I don't even understand or
do you just transact on the internet in
Mexican currency I don't know Sam Harvey
has signed up on YouTube Johnny Minogue
says what Western Mass food or drink
establishment do you miss the most -
Haymarket yeah so people people may or
may not know this but the David Pakman
show started where I went to high school
in Northampton Massachusetts were no
longer based there but I get back there
frequently I was actually just there my
family lives in that area generally and
I I do miss Haymarket I miss the absurd
humidity of Haymarket this is a cafe
where if you walk in wearing glasses
they immediately get completely fogged
up I miss the bathroom keys being left
inside the bathroom and causing a huge
line to congregate as people worry that
someone inside is doing something really
really bad only to find out that they
just left the key inside I really do
miss
a market and I look forward to getting
back there when I was there over the
weekend whoo I did pick up on the news
Cafe one of my favorite Northampton
restaurants was back open for take-out
I got a lentil soup I got the chicken
kebab on bag yet I mean it was a
delightful experience it's take out only
what else do I miss in Western Mass I
you know I I miss going to just go into
the roost or going to Northampton coffee
and just sitting there with my laptop
and you know answering emails and doing
work or just reading a book
kisara in East Hampton I believe the
best sushi in the area picked up food
there a couple months ago and Luis and
Mitch the owners were just doing takeout
already maybe it was like six weeks ago
or something like that I want to get
back to kisara there's so many places so
many places I'm the last place I went
out to eat in western mass was in
February I believe I went up to
Greenfield to hope in olive which is
also a great great restaurant okay Brad
Partington says Oh actually no hold on I
don't want fall behind on thanking
people thank you to essa qualm vid re
for the twitch subscription over on my
website I want to say thank you to
Whitney Whitney Cadwell who is new
member number 19 as well as a Neil Ebert
who is new member number two actually
you know what
Whitney cancelled how embarrassing
Whitney didn't subscribe Whitney
cancelled her membership okay that's
okay
so number 19 is a Neil Ebert there we go
and then number 20 is Melanie Anderson
okay now we are now at 20 and I can say
that for I can say that for sure oh boy
alright if you're just joining us we are
close to a half hour late with today's
press briefing apparently Kayleigh
McKenna knee taking after Donald Trump
and she also
we'll be starting the press briefings
late if you're watching on YouTube
please remember to hit the like button
and hit the subscribe button
both the it's really important it's free
and it helps us out dramatically music
55 says what does music 55 say do you
see the homeless numbers go up can trump
declare to the courts can't take homes
from renters most states right now have
no eviction and no foreclosure policies
I guess we would call them in place
but of course when those end people are
going to be behind on rent and mortgages
then it could get ugly so we'll have to
see how that goes Alvaro s says Boca Oh
Reba you know I don't really follow
Argentinian soccer I follow the national
team in the World Cup
I follow Copa America but I don't take a
position and I think you know hanging
out with my family is better as a result
because that can be very controversial
drew Reedy says did you see Oh a end
reporter Rhian Channel oh I think it's
Chanel Rio nor something like that come
out of the blue door was that odd I
didn't see it I didn't see it does if
anybody knows how long ago it was we
could go back to it must have been a
while ago looking here yeah I'm not
finding myself easily finding it here
but if somebody oh wait is this it oh I
think I did find it Oh yep that is her
why is she even there again that's why I
mean it's just her presence is
absolutely toxic okay so we found it now
I saw it thanks for calling my attention
to it
Townsend Koch says I agree with the gist
of your populism segment but social
democracy doesn't promote things like
workers on corporate boards and
Mondragon type coops I don't know that I
agree with you I don't know that I agree
with you let me give that a little more
thought
Joseph Dinsey says thoughts on the
Falklands War is it still controversial
in Argentina also what's your favorite
Italian Argentine food pizza the pizza
in Argentina
is fantastic you know here's the reality
I'm from Argentina I don't have any
emotional attachment to the Falklands
War and I don't know enough about it to
intelligently comment about it that
that's that's it I do find you know when
you go to a soccer match and there's
signs that say the Falklands Islands are
Argentinian I find that a little wacky
but I I'm not really the right person to
be uh you know explaining that war to
anybody Jared Johnson says I work online
I greatly enjoy your work I brought this
up because Republicans are upset about
people earning more while on
unemployment maybe they should be upset
about people working slave wages for
CEOs who rake in millions right that's
the counter to people could make more on
supplemented unemployment during the
virus than they normally do which is why
are people earning that little at
corporations where the CEOs have
absolutely absurd compensation packages
very good point Mitchell House says did
you get that phone line issue fixed I
believe we did we will see tomorrow we
will see tomorrow
um Sam Harvey says what where'd that go
Sam Harvey says just curious are you
concerned about Biden's cognitive state
love the show thanks for the awesome
content there's no question that Joe
Biden cognitively has slowed down from
where he was ten years ago I mean all
you have to do is look at look at the
2012 debate against Paul Ryan there's no
doubt about it
I've spoken to three different
neuroscience and mental health experts
none believes that Joe Biden has
dementia so you know but I don't take I
go by what experts say I don't come up
with this stuff on my own cuz it's not
my area of expertise and that's what
they are telling me let me say thank you
to Andrew Moore who is new member number
21 today Sherelle Roberts is new member
number 22 and Tom Wilson is new member
number 23 we may actually get to our
goal of 25 today we are we are very very
close I think partially thanks to Kaylee
Mack and Annie running very late now a
full half-hour late Matthias Germany
asks why is the press room so
small is it a historic room I don't know
the answer but it is when you see it
from the other side from I guess what
would be this camera up here or maybe
this one it's much smaller than people
imagine for sure a rich rope path acts
as trumps punctuality and his German
drum ancestry okay Barry Lee says David
do you have a coffee mug with your mug
shot printed on it pun intended because
I would buy one no we do not
Christie J says do you think using
Cayley Mack and Annie to spread the
Trump administration's lies helps Trump
politically or hurts him or neither
I find her almost more irritating than
Trump almost I have that same feeling
where I almost find her more irritating
than Trump but then I sort of don't
because really Trump is the problem she
exists as press secretary because of
Trump in a normal world someone like
Kaylee mcenany or Grisham would never be
press secretaries maybe Sean Spicer
would he did run communications for the
RNC but look at how long he lasted right
Ryan wild Grube says just a grant a
graduated nurse amazed how much better
British Columbia is doing than other
parts of Canada and developed world any
ideas as to why no I don't know enough
about the specifics of what's going on
within Canada to be able to say Zenda
crust says puffy hair beard gray t-shirt
quarantine chic this is actually one of
my cuts shirts one of one of our
sponsors they're actually pretty good I
like them
hair tieran says oh yeah I don't even
know that my hair really is puffy it
actually hasn't been puffy for a while I
mean we could do that we can make it
happen if people want by the way how
crazy I haven't done this for a couple
of weeks I didn't even realize how much
it had grown that is absolutely nuts
that is absolutely crazy but will will
keep it going for now the thing is I'd
have to lower my chair if it's going to
stay this way oh my god I've got like a
horn now there we go
all right that's good for now
okay pair Taryn says did Jarrod's
company kicked out residence or was it
stopped well yeah he's a slumlord I
don't know what's going on right now but
certainly they have evicted many many
people remember we are gonna start a
timer when Kayleigh comes out and see
whether she lies before or after the
three minute mark I believe she will lie
after the three minute mark but I'm also
trying to be proven wrong I'll start a
timer as soon as she comes out and and
we will see when she says her first
words how long it takes to lie Charlie
says David if you could teleport to the
briefing room what question would you
ask Kaley Mackin Annie I would ask her
about this video where she said Trump
will never allow the coronavirus to come
to the United States I would ask her
what she meant by that and if she's
ready to apologize
Sabrina zafar hey Sabrina would you
please have Kyle kolinsky on to discuss
some of your political differences in a
non combative manner I don't even know
what the differences are because I don't
watch any shows but my instinct is that
that type of thing at this point may be
more divisive than anything else
Ken H says did you hear Trump arguing
with a nurse about PPE I did and it was
awkward Sabrina's back and she says can
we have cop feffy tweet put on a TDP s
mug maybe I actually I used to love
coffe Fe I actually like have sefa hide
better now it has just a more it's less
halting it's easier to say it all right
here she is we'll switch over to the
White House feed and we will start a
timer and see whether she lies before or
after we reached the three minute mark
the White House feed is a little bit
behind but I prefer it I prefer it's my
favorite feed we are standing by here
don't worry you know well you'll be
twenty seconds delayed from the real
world but we are the stakes are low
enough that I prefer the actual White
House feed rather than this other one
geez maybe it's more than twenty seconds
behind but we should be very very close
there it is all right I will start the
stopwatch as soon as
speaks and we're off good afternoon
everyone I'd like to direct your
attention to a very encouraging graph
regarding test results it'll be over my
shoulder and hopefully on the screen for
those of you watching on television as
this chart shows the United States has
today 12 seconds that they already lied
5 million kroners test
it's an extraordinary number and as you
can see the United States irrelevant
what matters is per capita Trump was
walking around with this on a piece of
paper yesterday in Arizona
12 seconds until they deceived amazing
including the work of the Trump
administration for example the FDA has
issued over 70 emergency use
authorization x' to expand testing
capacity to accelerate the development
of therapeutics and vaccines there are
nearly 80 clinical trials ongoing with
an additional 30 clinical trials
expected Wow
this graph is also a testament to the
American people who have been and it's
no exaggeration American warriors as
they've followed social distancing
guidelines and taken steps to ensure
that the health and safety of our
vulnerable populations is protected
finally I would like to note that this
graph indicates that the US has
conducted double the number of tests
conducted and irrelevant we are 41st in
the world per capita it's it's actually
getting very it's one of these things
where they repeat it enough people start
to believe it it is irrelevant we have
331 million people cringing incredible
ingenuity and work ethic as you're well
aware President Trump has consistently
sided with the experts and has always
prioritized the health and safety of the
American people this includes issuing
guidance that meant hardworking
Americans had to stay home social
distance and slow the spread of the
virus this is what hard work of
Americans saved many lives remember it
was States who did stay at home orders
states not Trump country stayed home and
businesses temporarily shut their doors
President Trump
ensured American employees and employers
would receive the help that they need it
the Paycheck protection program provided
forgivable loans to small business
owners who kept their employees on
payroll
to date 2.3 million small business loans
have been processed with the average
loan being seventy six thousand dollars
in other words meaning that the small
businesses that needed the help them
notice that to point I mean like okay
can you is 2.3 million loans a lot or
not a lot how many business are a
business is out there how many people
applied how many we're not able to get
any money because huge corporations did
the number of loans is essentially
meaningless to most people it's like
imagining a trillion dollars for most
folks it's not really a tangible thing
that we can analyze breeders in the
military who started flags of valor in
2015
it's a veteran owned veteran run
manufacturing company located not too
far from here in Virginia flags of valor
builds wooden flags among other products
they've employed over their years 65
veterans and have raised over 1 million
dollars for veteran charities flags of
Valor is also proud to have 97 thousand
hours of American manufacturing labor
under their belt you got a lot of hours
at the start of this crisis Joe had to
furlough four of his employees again
does that number mean anything to
anybody pay cuts his employees were of
course disappointed but they were quote
in his words all in in the fight against
the coronavirus everything changed for
Joe and his furloughed employees when he
applied for the PPP loan just this week
he was approved for that PPP loan that
enabled flags of valor to rehire its
furloughed employees and to boost
paychecks back to pre coronavirus levels
PPP was a huge lifeline for us Joe told
me he called it a lifesaver this is a
perfect she's genuinely terrible at this
like really really bad we'll continue to
fight for small businesses and American
heroes like Joe Joe is here with me
today and I'd like to invite oh my god
propaganda look at this
can you imagine look at this degree of
propaganda twenty three hundred fifty
people died yet service thank you for
all the great work you've done for our
veterans and being a veteran yourself I
wanted to see if you'd take to the
podium for a minute or two and share
your message of hope with the American
can you imagine I'd love to thank you
Kaylee and Thank You president Ron for
allowing me to be here today I've got a
couple props
this is examples of
one of our products that we make and
here's another one this one is son
Gabriel made and when when you talk
about hope and what's going on so guys I
don't want to be if this is elitist then
by all means attack me but a wooden flag
it feels very kitchen isn't even the
right word it wouldn't flag I mean okay
great I love that this guy has a
business but I mean this this is who you
pick the Paycheck protection program
the two biggest fixed cost for most
businesses is people and property and
that's exactly what the PPP focused on
so for us it was a lifesaver it was an
absolute game changer we went from
trying to figure out how we were gonna
limit our cash burn every single day to
stay alive as long as we could there's
many people as we could to finally bring
them back and when you have to furlough
someone I'm telling you it is one of the
worst things you can do because you're
talking about family these are people
these are their wives their husbands
their children they're part of your
ethos and so what we've experienced is
been challenging Shore but when there
hasn't been all the revenue there's been
people helping other people and what we
approached it was how can we be better
how can we exit Cove in nineteen a
better version of ourselves how can we
innovate and so we saw people like the
US Chamber of Commerce the SBA step in
we saw our partners and Under Armour
step in we saw innovation you see
companies making respirator masks you
see all kinds of stuff going on and we
created the flag boat kit cuz families
were at home with their kids they didn't
know what to do with their children and
we believe this is our nation's family
crest so what better thing that allow
families to build American flags
together and talk about that and what it
means and then we started a twice a day
daily pledge at 9:00 a.m. in the morning
on the East Coast and again in 9:00 a.m.
on the west coast every day we've got
thousands of kids and their families
joining us to say the Pledge of
Allegiance almost four now I and all
that's happening by people coming
together is disgusting and and I can't
tell you enough how grateful we are to
the US government the bipartisanship
that took place to pass the Paycheck
protection taking everything I have not
to end this stream right now and to just
go punch myself in the face and they
built the parachute on the way down
when you think about it you want to talk
about the Lakers God or somebody else
got it think about the millions of
businesses that are being benefited by
this and it's I think 47% of us are
running interference and saying it's
okay that huge corporations took money
okay and so all the big businesses we
love they started as small businesses
and I hope to be a big mess of someday
but for now I'm happy to be alive in any
moronic so would work and thank you let
me be here so join us at flags of our
calm thank you
sponsored then go if you want to take a
seat with the reporters you can ask me
some questions oh my god Joe it's
veterans like you that make our country
great it's small business owners like
you that are gonna bring this country
back and employees like the one we heard
from last week Michael Hoyt the employee
a vidiian Bose coffee that keep this
country going so thank you so much for
the example you've set and to the
hard-working business owners across the
country to the employees across this
country who are working during this time
so thank you Joe thank you for your
service as I said PPP has changed lives
across this country and as president
Trump has said the American people are
warriors and we will fight together to
defeat the invisible enemy and with that
I'll take questions
oh my thanks Jo just to get back to this
decision that was supposedly coming
yesterday whose idea was it initially to
wind down the White House karna virus
task force look I would just refer you
back to the president's comments he's
been asked this like four times today I
believe he decided that coronavirus task
force is here to stay they have done
great he changed his mind after saying
yesterday it was time to end it because
of the backlash country through this
there were supposed to be 2.2 million
deaths and we're at a point that where
we're far lower than that in strengths
thanks to the great work of the task
force and to the leadership of President
Ron the death toll has just doubled
but we're still under 2 million so there
you go it's four times today I just
questioned about an ask so there were
some back-and-forth over the president
wearing a mask he has a mask Paige
prepared the White House is view
what is the White House's message to the
American people to the White House does
the president believe that people should
be wearing masks because they try to get
back to some semblance of their normal
life well as we put out it's recommended
but that's the choice of the individual
as to whether they wear a mask or not
the president yesterday the CEO of
Honeywell said that there was no need
and so he followed that advice and that
guidance and you know I would just note
on the note of mask 70 million in 95
Mathur mask page any questions about
Trump wearing a mask she's just gonna
say how many masks they've ordered can
you imagine our health care workers so
fact that in a few weeks we've
distributed nearly three times what is
used in a year is extraordinary and
that's not to mention the 120 million
surgical masks
he may be evil she may genuinely be evil
you I'm sure you've seen in a number of
holes there's a huge difference between
Democrats and Republicans over whether
or not they think it's necessary to wear
a mask why that would be no sense as to
why that would be that's the choice of
the American public's choice of the
individual as to whether to wear a mask
or not but again I'd praise the
extraordinary work of this
administration and distributing those
mass and ensure health care providers
even though Republicans aren't wearing
them it's Trump to be praised for
sending them out well as was the team
that they didn't need to wear masks the
reason he was told that is because the
people who would be interacting with him
had all been tested and had been shown
to be negative before that took place I
guess so the president had the
circumstances obviously he's the
president but why shouldn't all
Americans who go back to work be able to
get a test before they do to feel
comfortable in their own work
environments of anybody else let's
dismiss a myth about tests right now
what was going her a testing page single
American in this country at this moment
we have to retest them an hour later and
then an hour later after that because at
any moment you could theoretically
contract this virus so the notion that
everyone needs to be tested is just
simply nonsensical dependent again
nobody's saying everyone but at least
people going back to work at least
people going back to work we need to
surge nursing homes with the testing
meat processing facilities that's where
the testing is needed we have to be
strategic with our testing and we have
done that so far and again you know if
we want to talk about testing and the
volume of testing the
fact that in South Korea there are we
always hear about South Korea and their
tests there are 11 tests per thousand
here in the United States that 17 tests
per thousand our hot spots per capita
are yep that's 41st in the world where
we are 41st in the world best of other
countries around the world we're at a
very strong place in this country of
testing but rest assured we'll deploy it
strategically because that's what the
American public expects of us Father to
be clear should people I guess should
people accept the risk that they could
become it all if they go back to work
look each and every state has put into
place this is a governor led effort
first of all let me emphasize that the
president wait a second so Trump is to
be praised for all of his work but
anything not working well is the fault
of Gov it okay I gotcha gotcha Kaley
okay very safely reopen I was sitting in
the meeting when Admiral Zhao pulled out
the list for several states and said
here's the testing you were requested to
open safely here's the testing I'm
giving you to meet that need it's pretty
extraordinary this wide scale effort by
the Trump administration to ensure
states have what they need so as States
reopen they'll do so safely and they'll
do so with the supplies of the Trump
administration say that so many those
what does it say that so many of those
governors those days aren't following
the guidelines that the president
dictated from this podium we encourage
every single governor to follow the
guidelines that we've put forward to a
phased reopening approach we have this
beautiful concept called federalism
which means that and that's what that's
what we're doing we encourage everyone
to follow the expert written guidelines
that we've put forward you have a
question about about reopening but but
first the some of the areas that have
been hardest hit by coronavirus have
been in urban areas what is the White
House do
or is there any targeted effort to help
stop the spread in the morning
communities yeah it's a very important
question because we know that some of
our underserved communities are hit most
by the coronavirus absolutely we've done
quite a bit I'm invested first of all
1.4 billion dollars into our nation's
13,000 community centers that ensures
that 28 million people living in
medically underserved areas receive
funding also that announcement I had for
us last week about hospital funding two
billion dollars yes mm was was geared
towards specifically ensuring and men
and women in underserved communities and
those hospitals got that money and I
would also know just that the president
has directed secretary ben Carson to
focus the White House opportunity and
revitalization Council on underserved
communities so very important this is a
community that's been very hard hit and
rest assured we are laser focused on
making sure that these communities are
assisted okay so the task force has put
out faith's guidelines for states to
reopen an individual guidelines but it
hasn't said very much about businesses
specifically does it plan to put out any
detailed guidelines for businesses like
retailers and restaurants reopen go on
the phased approach there are some
recommendations for how for instance a
restaurant should reopen on a distancing
that's required and as you go through
the phases that distancing em is shrunk
and there are other mechanisms that are
outlined for restaurants and movie
theaters and sporting venues so I would
argue that our phased approach does take
that into account in each and every
state by the way the governor is welcome
to reach out to us right it's gently
communicating with the governor's and
when I say we the administration meaning
dr. Burks
and others so we are happy to consult
with with regard to specific details
some other organ is outside
organizations how quick can you imagine
being a governor and being like hey I'm
not sure what I should do I'm gonna call
Trump and get his advice like imagine
being that clueless that you think
Trump's the person who needs to help you
figure out what to do many of those
guidelines are within we've consulted
individually with states that as I said
at the government governor led effort
it's a state-led effort I'm in which the
federal government will consult and we
do so each and every day
you use the phrase warriors in front of
everyday Americans the president using
that phrase as well what's the thinking
behind using that description and is
that basically asking America to put
themselves in harm's way if you have a
wailing warriors death not in the
slightest it's actually the opposite you
know the president's been clear that not
at this moment you know we're at a
wartime moment where we're fighting the
invisible enemy and by that I mean
beloved 19 and on the contrary the the
notion that the American people are
warriors they're warriors because
they've stayed home they're warriors
because they've social distance they're
warriors because this mitigation effort
is something that could only be done by
the American people coming together I
can see the commercials now I am
fighting a battle against a freezer full
of mochi and trying to resist going and
eating the entire thing guidelines I
know it's been difficult I know it's
been hard but it's because of you that
we're at this place where we can reopen
the country clear that's the opposite
what the president says specifically
because he says Americans must be
warriors to reopen the economy I'm
saying they've already been worried by
saying oh all right they're all worried
we're saying the exact same thing
they're saying they're warriors either
heirs to reopen because guess what in
order to get to reopening you have to
social distance right you had to put it
together the war was staying home first
now the war is going out and getting the
virus um the one of the lowest mortality
rates in the world and that's because of
the American we have the 14th highest
mortality rate in the world 14th highest
mortality rate in the world about best
practices but first on China and some of
the comments that the president made in
the Oval Office he said that there will
be a report coming out next week ten
days or so as to whether or not they're
living up to
China is as it stands though right now
at this moment how does the White House
view the u.s. relationship with China
right now right now it's a relationship
of disappointment and frustration
because the president has said how
frustrated he is that some of the
decisions of China put American lives at
risk I'll share just a few that China
for instance did not share the genetic
sequence until after a professor in
Shanghai did so on his own and after
that genetic sequence was shared the
next day the lab was shut down for quote
rectification the World Health
Organisation's slow-walked information
on human to human transmission
adequately provided by China China
didn't let us investigators in and look
that those decisions put American lives
at risk and the president is certainly
not happy about that and as president
said you'll be hearing more about that
next day's horrors sorry maybe trusted
business partners the president has
worked with China and stood up to China
and got the Phase one China deal a huge
win 250 billion dollars the president
managed to get that done and the
president appreciates that that China
got us to that point of the Phase one
China deal so you know I'll leave it to
the President as to how we move forward
and I certainly won't get ahead of him
on that to best practices we heard the
president say as it relates to schools
that he wants to see schools open but
maybe teachers who are old older than 60
not necessarily come back into the
classroom when you've talked about
reopening the economy reopening the
country again there's a lot of people
out there wondering well my school-aged
child should they come back into contact
with a family member who might be older
than 64 right what is the White House
advice upon that and families who are
all over the country saying is it 3ww
well the president the task force have
been clear that vulnerable Americans are
senior citizens need to shelter in place
and they need to take extra measures of
precaution because as we know they've
been disproportionately affected by the
coronavirus so I certainly would include
the senior community to continue to
follow the guidelines we've put forward
dr. Burks says mentioned an influx of
asymptomatic coronavirus cases and
without more widespread testing how do
you get a handle on something like that
and how do you keep people but the most
funny thing we have domestic yeah so
it's an important question we get
information on asymptomatic spread when
we test in the meat processing
facilities and other facilities again
you know we can just test strategically
and it's important that once we test and
we find I'm an example of someone who
has corona virus that we can contact
trace and ensure that it's not spread to
other members of the community so
contact tracing is an important measure
and we're testing strategically and in
line with governor's John what's the
process
Kaleigh for the distribution and access
to REM disappear yeah Ramdev severe is a
great example of innovation in this
country and has nothing to do with is a
drug that the president mentioned it
often so and right on cue so listen I
told you guys about this drug as well as
seven or eight others months ago Trump
had nothing has nothing to do with room
desert at all and in fact he pushed
hydroxychloroquine as if it were a
miracle cure they now we're going to
talk about room des vir if it's good as
if it has anything to do with Trump even
though it has nothing to do with Trump
or giving these 1.5 million vials which
will help a lot of Americans around the
country but what's the process for
distributing it and giving access to
patients I don't have any information on
that
as of now that's the answer everything
she said before that was not an answer
the president said yesterday he does not
want dr. Fauci testifying before the
house oh she's got a page on with Trump
haters how was that consistent with
oversight and transparency well first of
all um but the president noted was
specific to the house it's important to
know that doctor felt you will be
testifying before the Senate right the
Republican Senate's a fine place for him
to go yeah both Democrats and
Republicans the house however and
specifically chairwoman Nita Lowey city
did not act in good faith marked meadows
had three calls with chairwoman Nita
Lowey three nights ago when she called
task doctor felt she could testify
before a subcommittee hearing and chief
of staff mark meadows has made clear he
wants to make the best use he can of the
task force members time of course
they're working hard to save American
lives so that's very important so to
that end he said in the three phone
calls you know what is the purpose of
this hearing can you give me the subject
matter and LOI was unable to tell the
chief of staff what the subject matter
was the last phone call they had was at
ten forty six and LOI agreed to follow
up in the morning with details those
details were never received in the hope
we got a press release so that's what we
call a publicity stunt we encourage the
house to act in good faith but much like
the Senate did and as I noted dr. Fauci
will be speaking in a week and a half
before the Senate so the notion that
he's being blocked is just farcical
about the way the death toll is being
calculated is lower so the president
answered this and he said no just a few
moments ago in the Oval Office on the
mortality rate I would note as I noted
in just a few moments ago we have one of
the lowest in the world we have the 14th
highest mortality rate per capita in the
world folks okay I need all the you know
six seven thousand people that are
watching across all of our platforms
right now any time they say that we have
the 14th highest mortality rate in the
world from coronavirus because of the
work of the American people we have
escaped that 2.2 million number because
of the extraordinary social distancing
effort put in place I think keep up with
all
way back the president have said many
times that he's received praise in phone
calls with foreign leaders because of
this administration's response to the
corona virus outbreak who exactly are
those heads of state and heads of
governments who are praising this
administration for its response
well I won't some reveal any contents of
his private conversations with world
leaders but I will certainly share some
of the very public comments from
Democrat governors like Gavin Newsom
that wasn't the question every single
direct request that President Trump that
he was president Trump was key person
was foreign leaders Trump claims are
calling him and congratulating him and
asking him for how he did such great
things not Gavin Newsom extremely
responsive in our hour of need whether
it was ventilators we got a huge amount
of supplies to test and of course I love
the ones from Governor Andrew Cuomo who
praised this administration's for a
response is phenomenal
saying he's delivered for New York the
Army Corps of Engineers we thought that
he sent the Navy ship comfort to New
York he has delivered for New York
President Trump has delivered for this
nation thank you
the president was talking earlier about
dr. bright being a disgruntled employee
one of the allegations in that
whistleblower complaint is that in
January when there was still a huge
shortage of 95 masks right that he had
excuse me been in contact with a company
that was offering up to a million of
those masks and he couldn't get anybody
HHS willing to engage with that company
which then subsequently exported 1
million and 95 to China right is that
something that you're looking into or
concerned about ok Tom on issues of dr.
bright I'd refer you to HHS I'm not
going to get involved with the personnel
issues or the substance of that
complaint but I will once again I know
you mentioned masks 70 million Plus
delivered and again that's three times
the amount used by healthcare providers
in any given year so yes most of them in
April when we had an opportunity in
January to get ahead of this
the question about teachers and what the
president said earlier about keeping
those who are 60 or older out of the
classroom what is the message to older
Americans should they not do anything
not meet their homes until there is a
vaccine or what would the president have
them do
well our task force has said that
vulnerable communities like our seniors
should shelter in place that being said
we encourage every American if you have
a symptom that is pressing that you need
to go to your WH and disturb to read
many quotes from doctors I'm stories of
people who are staying home with chest
pain and don't hospital when they could
be on the verge of having a heart attack
who are missing important appointments
like mammograms screenings like
colonoscopies it's important that we as
Americans continue to go to our doctors
to get medically necessary procedures
and when we have symptoms that are that
need to be addressing like chest pain
that you do go to your doctor should
should seniors stay home until there's a
vaccine if you have chest pain you
should go to the hospital that that's
the question and answer of a symptom
like that in a separate chamber acting
DNI Brunel has stated this week that
he's prepared to release
about 6,000 pages worth of transcripts
relating to atom shifts can you confirm
whether or not the executive branch is
conducting any kind of investigation
into House members or potentials at home
doing or is that something you can
comment on yet that's not the first time
hearing of that says no it was not the
Jeff's question about dr. pouchy and in
the president's statement that too many
Trump haters in the house I mean it does
the White House really believe that you
can decide to have officials testifying
the republican-controlled Senate but not
testify in the Democratic controlled
house does that timelessly
have legitimate oversight and legitimate
Trump doesn't responsibility not just
not just the you know authority but
responsibility to have somebody like you
testifying
dr. Fauci be questioned by Democrats in
that Senate hearing yes it's what so
what are you saying that so the Senate's
fine the house has no role in oversight
the house needs act in good faith we
don't have time in the middle of a
pandemic for publicity stunts it's not
the time what do you call you should be
able to give the subject-matter to
ensure it's the best use of doctor fell
and the republican-controlled Senate
maybe South Korea can help us somehow
they seem to know what's going on we're
screwed
in a previous life before you were press
secretary you work for the campaign and
you made a comment I believe on Fox here
we go that President Trump will not
allow the coronavirus to come to this
country loved it given what has happened
since then obviously would you like to
take that back well first let me note I
was asked a question on Fox Business
about president's travel restrictions I
noted what was the intent behind those
travel Rob terrorism come here referring
to an earlier set of travel restrictions
I guess I would turn the question back
on the media and ask similar questions
does Vox want to take back that they
proclaim that the coronavirus would not
be a deadly pandemic does the Washington
Post want to take back that the none of
those people have been hired to be the
press secretary a virus which is the
Washington Post likewise want to take
back that our brains are causing us to
exaggerate the threats of the corona
virus does the New York Times want to
take back that fear of the virus may be
expressive spreading faster than the
virus itself does NPR want to take back
that the flu was a much bigger threat
than the corona virus and finally once
again the Washington Post would they
like to take back but the government
should not respond aggressively to the
corona virus I'll leave you with those
questions but maybe you'll have some
answers that's it 35 minutes late for a
25 minute press briefing where the only
questions actually answered were I
haven't heard of that or I can't speak
to that every other answer was not an
answer right should seniors stay home
until there's a vaccine if you have
chest pain you should go to the hospital
that's not an answer the only actual
answers were I'm I've not heard of that
I can't comment on that I can't speak to
that I can't disclose that and as soon
as she was asked about this embarrassing
event on Fox which I'll play for you she
doesn't actually answer and ends the
press briefing remember this guy's just
a matter of protecting us our national
security really being at stake
he's sort of the last line of defense
there or firstly I should say absolutely
this president will always put America
first he will always protect American
citizens we will not see diseases like
the corona virus come here we will not
see terrorism come here and isn't that
refreshing when contrasting it with the
awful presidency approach soon as that
was brought up she just leaves and bails
Wow Wow the degree to which we are
screwed because these people are in
charge is difficult to even encompass
with language thanks for joining me
today we will be back with new clips the
rest of today and tomorrow and we'll see
what live events there are tomorrow I
will see you then if there are any
you